- Valentine's is a few days away.
I know this is a big
holiday for you right?
- Yes.
In my country, it's the day
of the love and of friendship.
So what a beautiful day.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And, in my house it's pretty big
because it's an anniversary that I have
with my husband and it's
also my daughter's Saint Day.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- [Audience] Aww.
- Yes.
So it's a big day.
- So, wait, you once got a big
surprise on Valentine's Day?
- [Salma] Yes.
- What was it?
- So, I was engaged for a long time
but every time it was getting
close I would chicken out.
- Oh why?
- [Salma] like three, four times?
Look, I didn't get married until I was 41,
so I always had a phobia
for the marriage thing.
- Yeah.
I understand.
- [Salma] And so I was kind of famous
for it in my (indistinct).
(Salma sighs)
So anyway, my husband
flew my parents secretly,
and on Valentine's Day,
they took me to the court,
like on an intervention.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Like, I don't like this dress.
I have to get a (indistinct).
And,
they say sign!
They spoke in French.
I don't know what they were saying.
I was looking at (indistinct).
And I did it.
And that's my first wedding.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Surprise wedding on Valentine's Day.
(audience applauding)
Do you know I married him four times?
- What?
- I've married Francois four times.
- [Kelly] But what do you mean?
- Never been divorced.
Because then after I was
like, ah, and I said,
"Okay, I kind of like it
that I'm married now."
(audience and Kelly laughing)
I wanna party.
(audience applauding)
And so we made a huge party.
but I didn't like the cake.
(Kelly laughing)
I was waking in my honeymoon.
"Why did I take that cake, it
looked like from outer space,
I just wanted a normal wedding cake."
And so we went on a vacation
and then I did a surprise wedding for him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- With a nice proper wedding cake.
- You know?
(audience laughing)
And then-
- Why the fourth one?
- Because recently we went to
the same place with the kids
because the third one
was just with the kids.
The whole family went to the same place.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then they all surprised
me with the same thing
but reverse.
Now he surprised me without-
- [Audience] Aww.
- Oh, that's nice.
- The cake was okay.
(audience laughing)
- I will say-
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- But I'm not a control freak.
(audience laughing)
- It's actually not fair
how unbelievably talented, hot,
and funny you are.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
It's not fair.